beware of falling squid in the mom from
Titanic because it's HBO's newest series
Watchmen that hopefully won't end in
disaster and who has a better story and
brand the broken bra in this video I'll
be taking a deep dive into the episode
and discuss some theories on where the
series might be headed so strap in
because here we go
Watchmen begins in the style of an early
1900s movie depicting the arrest of a
corrupt lawman at the hands of what
appears to be a hooded vigilante this
vigilante turns out to be famous
real-life u.s. marshal bass Reeves who
was the first black marshal in the
United States and during his time as
marshal arrested more than 3,000 felons
the all-white townspeople clap and thank
him for his service which is in direct
contrast to what we're about to find in
1921 Tulsa Oklahoma the setting for the
1921 Tulsa race riots in which over a
hundred black men and women were killed
a 2001 commissioners report concluded
that the city had conspired with the mob
of white citizens to systematically
stifle and kill its black citizens were
introduced to this man simply known as
the father who takes his son to be sent
away from the violence of the city
writing on a piece of paper watch over
this boy the sad irony of it all is that
a man who joined the armed forces to
protect his country is so shamelessly
betrayed by it but the symbolism of a
new America rising from the ashes is
shown through the wrapping of a young
child in the American flag as the old
America burns in the background
flash-forward almost a hundred years to
2019 Tulsa this policeman Charlie Sutton
just like bass Reeves in the
introduction wears a mask to protect his
real identity and will later find that
all lawmen do this a routine traffic
stop gives us our first introduction to
a member of the cavalry seen here by the
brief glimpse of the Rorschach mask in
the glove compartment the cavalry is a
white supremacist organization whose
members wear wore Shaq masks in honor of
Walter Kovacs the original Rorschach
from the graphic novels at the end of
the novel Rorschach delivers his journal
to a right-wing publication called the
new frontiersman but how exactly this
manifested in the creation
the cavalry is yet to be known this
scene also gives us valuable insight
into the world of 2019 Tulsa has
skyscrapers there these what seemed to
be power generators along the highway
officers must get permission before
using their weapons yet there doesn't
seem to be any laptop cell phones or
Internet the officer asked permission to
use his weapon from a man known as Panda
I'm doubting that's his real name so I
think it's fair to assume like the mass
this is an effort to protect one's
identity unfortunately for the officer
it's too little too late and he's
viciously gunned down by the cavalry
member an event which sparks sheriff
Judd Crawford to miss the rest of his
Oklahoma performance at the hospital
were introduced to a character known as
Looking Glass a top and Tara Gator and
behavioral scientist Judd asked him to
make sure background checks are
conducted on all the nurses and
orderlies who saw the officers face once
again hinting that things are so bad in
this alternate world that the utmost
care in protecting one's identity is
taken we've learned that the cavalry has
been relatively quiet and for them to do
such a brazen attack like this is out of
the ordinary so whatever was in this
guy's truck was likely something very
important
Judd visits Charlie's wife asking her to
lie about what happened that it was a
carjacking gone wrong we're starting to
get a better sense at the extreme
lengths Judd will go to protect the
identity of his officers but whether
there are alternative motivations for
this remain to be seen we also get this
brief shot of dr. Manhattan on Mars
playing Sam Cassell having sequestered
himself there and opted to stay away
from the affairs of humanity after the
events of the graphic novel were then
introduced to Angela a bar a baker with
a mysterious past she was born in
Vietnam which we learn is now an
American state likely after the success
of the war due to dr. Manhattan there
she was a police officer and we get our
first reference to the white knight an
event which led to the creation of laws
requiring officers to wear masks to
protect their identities you can also
make out the current President of the
United States in the background here
Robert Redford and the use of the term
Redford ations a play on the word
reparations whether these reparations
are for her getting shot or for what the
US did in Vietnam
remains to be seen but it's an awkward
thing to be brought up so much so that
Angela's son Topher beats up his
classmate Tommy for mentioning it it's
also possible that Redford Asians are
reparations for years of slavery but we
just simply don't know at this time
Topher tells his mother all he was
trying to do was stand up for her when
all of a sudden it begins to rain squid
we get this shot of a giant air-raid
siren that warns people of upcoming
squid showers and on it it says squid
information tune in to AM 560 even the
back of the road maintenance vehicle
here has a picture of a squid and right
behind Tommy in class is a poster
depicting the anatomy of one squid also
happens to be the name of adrian veidt's
secret project that teleported a giant
squid like mutation to New York which
killed millions this squid reign is
somehow connected to this outside the
abar home we meet Angela's husband Cal
and daughter Rosie notice the alternate
US flag which has more than 50 states on
it Angela gets a pager stating little
bighorn and not to the 1876 Battle of
Little Bighorn in which combined forces
of the Lakota Northern Cheyenne and
Arapaho tribes defeated General Custer
and the 7th Cavalry Regiment Little
Bighorn seems to be a call to arms to
fight against the now modern-day 7th
cavalry and yes we have advertisements
for the latest hit TV show American hero
story Minutemen recounting the tale of
the original Minutemen heroes on the bus
you can even make out hooded justice the
first-ever masked Avenger as angela
passes through the streets we see a
mural of the dreamland theater the same
one from the beginning and this
newspaper here has some fun information
such as Adrian Veidt officially declared
dead
Adrian also known as Ozymandias was one
of the original members of the watchmen
he was the one that created the giant
squid in order to trick the world in
uniting against a common alien enemy
thereby averting World War 3 there's
also two other articles KKK vandalism
forces Statue of Liberty closure perhaps
because the KKK hate the symbol of
welcoming immigrants and Boise squid
shower destroys homeless camp kills too
now here we have an old man asking when
Angela's bakery will open and I can't
help but think this is the same boy from
the beginning
even though that would make him over 100
years old
notice how both the boy and the man have
the same mole on the side of their face
yes sir if she thinks he can lift 200
pounds a very odd question but perhaps
this is because at the end of the
episode this is exactly what we'll see
the back of the bakeries were Angela
keeps her costume for her heroic
alter-ego sister night a cross wielding
masked Avenger also fun to notice the
code for the back room is 1985 when the
events of the original Watchmen take
place as she drives off we see the
Williams Dream Land theater playing
Oklahoma and the Nixon Ville trailer in
this alternate universe Nixon was never
impeached and held office for at least
five terms sister Knight punches a
suspect she believes to be involved with
Charlie Sutton's murder and makes her
way to the police department where the
seventh cavalry has sent a warning to
the police in it the 7th cavalry have
taken Rorschach's lined up soon the
world will shout save us and we will
whisper no and revised it too soon all
the [ __ ] and race traders will shout
save us and we will whisper no so it
seems like they've taken this Rorschach
journal and twisted it to fit their own
worldview in the meeting other masked
officers like pirate Jenny and Red Scare
have joined all of whom want Judd to
enact article 4 which allows a 24-hour
use of firearms without having to go
through Panda to release them Judd ends
the meeting with the Latin phrase key
custodiet Ipsos custodes which
translates to who watches the Watchers
in which the group responds we watch
them sister night shows up in Judds
office like she owns the place drinking
from an owl mug which may be a small nod
to night owl
she asked Judd if she can put her perp
in the pod to which he agrees we get our
first glimpse of the pod a device which
allows lookingglass to tell whether or
not a perpetrator is lying we get some
interesting images here like Richard
Nixon on Mount Rushmore and General
Custer when they talk about the 7th
cavalry looking last mentions
transdimensional attacks referring to
how Adrian Veidt teleported a giant
squid like creature in the 1980s this
suspect is deemed to be a liar and
sister Knight goes to town on him in an
attempt to find out who shot their
fellow officer
the suspect informs them of a cattle
ranch where members of the seventh
Cavalry are collecting batteries from
watch
is what they'll be used for we'll find
out in episodes to come sister night
goes after the shooter and after she's
successful takes a moment to look at
this at four dollar bill one of the
original Minutemen grabbing a young
black boy but before she can question
the shooter he takes what appears to be
a cyanide pill while the others get away
Jud and pirate Jenny chased them in an
airship that looks eerily similar to
night owls they're able to take down the
criminal plane but not without crashing
their own galloping through what appears
to be the English countryside is the
home of Adrian Veidt take a Ozymandias
notice the shape of the building here
looks markedly similar to the structure
dr. Manhattan destroys on Mars
dr. Manhattan has his reasons for hating
Adrian as Adrian was the one responsible
for framing him as being responsible for
the interdimensional squid attack that
killed millions but let's also be wary
that his name is actually never spoken
and we saw earlier in the paper that
Adrian is dead so either this takes
place in a different time or dimension
it's not Adrian at all or that his death
was a hoax and he lives in solitude or
at least with his servants who I suspect
are some sort of robots as evidenced by
mr. Phillips handing him a horseshoe
instead of a knife and the bad tasting
cake they baked him remember that
Ozymandias is extremely wealthy and is
known for making futuristic technology
so this is totally within the realm of
possibility they're celebrating his
anniversary but were never told exactly
what anniversary it's for he's also
written a play called the watchmakers
son and dr. Manhattan just happens to be
the son of a watchmaker so there's some
sort of connection there at dinner Jud
snort some cocaine a problem Angela
seems to be aware of the bird's eye view
here looks like an eye like someone or
something is watching them Angela is
concerned about the duffel bag of
batteries found from the crash site
they're made of synthetic lithium which
were discontinued after they were found
to have caused cancer in the novel dr.
Manhattan was framed by Adrian who
accused him of causing the cancer that
killed his coworkers judge tells the
governor he has everything under control
when he's paged by the hospital that
Charlie Sutton has woken up and we get
this weird photo of what appears to be a
younger Judd with his father while
making his way over to the hospital we
hear over the radio the mention of
Senator Kean the man who tabled the
infamous
Teaneck which ban costume crime-fighters
save those sanctioned by the government
it appears that his son Joe jr. will be
running against president Redford who
has been in office now for 30 years
Judds car is taken out by tire spikes in
Angela receives a mystery phone call
from the man in the wheelchair who has
magically strung up Judd at the ripe old
age of a hundred and five he's still
holding the letter watch over this boy
the song poor Judd is dead from Oklahoma
plays as a drop of blood smears on his
badge just like on the happy face symbol
of the original Watchmen graphic novel
now we can assume that the wheelchair
man wasn't the one to prop Judd up on
that tree but that he's working with
someone else I also believe that series
creator Damon Lindelof will likely
incorporate time-travel into this season
or perhaps multiple dimensions we
already know that Lindelof has played
with time on loss and the Watchmen
universe has dealt with transporting
creatures from other dimensions leaving
me to believe this may not be the last
time we see Jed after all what was the
point of this photo here if he didn't
have some role to play in future
episodes comment below if you have an
answer it's still too early to solidify
some of the major theories out there but
I hope you'll stick with me as I break
down all the watchmen episodes make sure
to give the video a like and subscribe
and let me know what you thought about
the first episode you can also reach me
on twitter at things story whitey
until next time remember daddy loves you
very much